I was torn about whether to talk to
Donald Trump on this podcast as a
historian what would you advise
I think uh I mean you know this is uh
this is a difficult question right um
for for historians who want um you know
sort of want
uh to make sure that they know sort of
what Americans are thinking and talking
about
um you know uh four centuries later so
one of the the things that you know at
least my understanding is that when uh
president Trump was banned from Twitter
his account was also deleted
um and that is one of the most valuable
sources that historians will use and to
understand that the era and parts of it
were sort of you know archived and
reconstructed but uh you know but in
that sense I think that that is also a
real loss to the historical record
um I mean I think that uh your podcast
shows you'll you'll talk to you'll talk
to anyone um so I'm here right right
um so you know I'm not in in the
business of saying you know don't don't
don't talk don't talk that's one of the
difficult things when I think about
Hitler I think
um Hitler's Stalin I don't know if World
War One quite has the same intensity
of
controversial leaders
but one of the sad things from a
historian perspective is how few
interviews Hitler has given or Stalin
has given and
that's such a difficult thing because
it's obvious that talking to Donald
Trump
that talking to Xi Jinping talking to
Putin
is really valuable from a historical
perspective to understand
but then you think about the momentary
impact of such a conversation and you
think
well depending on how the conversation
goes you can steer
or uh Flame
what does it feed the flame of War or
conflict or
um
abuses of power and things like this and
that's I think the tension between the
journalists and the historian
because when a journalists interview
dictators for example
one of the things that strikes me
is they're often
very critical of the dictator
they're they're like um
they're basically attacking them in
front of their face
as opposed to trying to understand
because what I perceive they're doing is
they're signaling to uh the other
journalists that they're on the right
side of History kind of thing
um but that's not very productive and
it's also why the dictators and leaders
often don't do those interviews it's not
productive to understand who the human
being is to understand you have to
empathize
um because few people I think few
leaders do something
from a place of malevolence I think they
really do think they're doing good
and not even for themselves not even for
selfish reasons I think they're doing
great for the they're doing the right
thing for their country
or for whoever the group they're leading
and to understand that you have to
and and by the way a a large percent of
the country often supports them I bet if
you pull legitimately poor people North
Korea they will believe that their
leader is doing the right thing for
their country
um and so to understand that
you have to empathize so that's the
tension of the journalist I think and
the historian because obviously the
historian doesn't doesn't care they
really want to they care obviously
deeply but they they know that history
requires deep understanding of the human
being the full context
uh yeah it's a tough decision to make
yeah well I think it's uh both for
journalists and historians the challenge
is not to be too close to your subject
right um and you know not to be
um overly influenced and used by them
right you know when you're talking to a
living subject which historians do you
know um too
um you know it's it's a matter of making
sure that you triangulate their story
with with the the rest of the record
right
um and that may paint a different
picture of of the person than
um and will prevent you as a journalist
or a historian from kind of you know
just telling someone else's story
okay and so and historians also have the
benefit of going back you know 30 40
years and finding all the other stories
and figuring out you know uh playing two
truths and a lie you're like which parts
are you know which parts are accurate
which are which are not and journalists
do that work in a day-to-day basis but
historians um you know we get a little
more time to think about what we're
doing
well I I personally also think it's
deeply disrespectful to the populace
to people
to
um censor and ignore a person that's
supported by a very large number of
people
like that you oh I personally feel like
you owe the citizens of this country
a deep uh empathy and understanding of
the leaders they support
even if you disagree with what they say
I mean that's the the to me I'm much
more worried about the resentment of the
censorship
um that it's
to having a good conversation with
Donald Trump is ultimately valuable
uh because he I think
especially in this case I agree with you
that Donald Trump is not a singular
person he is a he represents a set of
feelings that a large number of people
have and whatever those feelings are you
can try to figure out by talking to
people but also talking to the the the
the man and then seeing the interplay
there what does this really represent
in this period in history in this slice
of the world
um yeah ultimately understanding I think
leads to uh compassion and love and
unity which is how this whole thing
progresses the tension between the
different sides is useful to um
have a good conversation but ultimately
coming up with the right answer and
progressing towards that answer is how
you make progress